hello super super early good morning to
everyone to anthem premiere access or
premiere origin access day the fun fact
is I'm in I've been playing already a
little bit because we have like review
copy so I didn't get super far or
anything I had mentioned in chat earlier
that the game is a lot harder on hard
now compared to the demo and I don't
know if that's just because I'm lacking
gear but let me preface this a couple
things obviously if you're worried about
spoilers you know this is supposed to be
and so I'm probably like two missions in
this is like the third baby mission
there's some tutorial stuff this is like
the third mission though I had to had
problems last night I was gonna play on
my laptop but I don't know for some
reason it just wasn't like loading it
was like a I don't know some type of
weird bug that I had actually previously
on laptops but it definitely works on
thingy and I beat the loading screen box
yeah I don't know how many people were
actually trying to get in you know that
are trying to get in now like I don't
okay see clearly we've got some problems
nope there it is
as I say that oh I'm dead cool
good morning to everyone
also just all know it is day one I
wouldn't be shocked if there's some some
like kind of loading stuff problems
what's up Corinne yeah my bday was great
we stayed in and ate pizza
alright at least I'm not too far from
where I was I go I see you unlock your
first javelin at level 2 I'm like
roughly level 3 right now
like like the damage is real man fun
hard I don't know if I'm gonna play hard
the rest of the way but so far like I
can't actually even tell if it's worth
it I haven't dropped any like greens or
anything and it's just making my life
way harder also with the kind of like
probably day 1 latency type stuff might
not be worth it but you know I'm lower
level
please it's too early in the morning for
this
yes everything hurts real bad a lot
harder than also maybe because I'm
playing storm I Wow
[Music]
where are my hammers that was had like
half shield and whole life and like that
melted half my life just from a couple
scars you
I had they connected I'm trying to
connect I had review poppy so I've
actually been in since about 6:30 that's
how I got in so I'm sure we're gonna
have a bunch of people youtubers and all
that stuff come in
asked like are they in well I just kind
of told you
the rest fever
there's another dude that I just didn't
use my ultimate on that's not good there
is totally another dude
the portal which is not good
so if I don't get to chat right now I
apologize I'm trying not to die cut a
hell of a time ready this morning well I
feel like since you guys are watching
and all that stuff kind of step up my
game also I haven't had coffee yet which
is like whoo
since I don't work on YouTube chat
oh why if it does I can implement it
crime but that is a good point that he
does made
do they not go wait I killed the big
dude maybe
although private easier just to farm the
little dudes until we get all back
[Music]
there's loss
like in freezing
I guess it's good that is hard though
so you want to challenge I would say
part mode is quite a bit harder than
I'll just say be very but even the
normal list of dudes could really wreck
you
no save me
please help
I get out angry
he's like super pissed right now hello
I do not want it's Valentine's Day is
past I have a Valentine ready her name
is Corinne I don't want to clean out the
rest of them oh my what a combo all
right we got it was the progress we
saved to launch yes
at least for me I was told my progress
will carry over if you guys are worried
about cutscenes spoilers obviously I can
skip them I don't really mind that scars
so but obviously we're playing through
story and all that so I just want you
guys to know that four Runner King sing
first thing I noticed about this from
watching is that this feels like what
Mass Effect should have been we're
supposed to feel like and yeah there
have definitely been people in the
office that have been saying that and
they're excited about it because of that
yeah you have to have origin premiere
access to play today
no don't skip all right I don't mind I
won't skip it's out for anyone that has
premiere origin access so if you do the
subscription I think it's like once a
month it's 15 bucks or for a year it's a
hundred but you basically don't have to
like buy the game
you can just do origin access and it
started at 7:00 a.m. like I mentioned
earlier I have a review code so that's
why I'm in already and that's why I'm
probably a little bit farther than some
other folks but I'm not that far I
actually really wanted to play a bunch
last night but I just didn't get to I
didn't get a chance to cuz I had some
problems myself yes as Michael says you
can also get 10 hours on Xbox confirmed
its on xbox on PC but for PC it's 10
hours and then I'm sorry Xbox is 10
hours PC it's like unlimited from what I
know origin axis is not EA access it I
it it's I just know it as origin
premiere access I think is the proper
terminology if I'm getting that wrong
I'm sorry it's early
oh crap see I just knocked out on a
headset I'm sure somebody can correct me
how much are skins we can take a look
thanks for the save this was different
something's making the scars more
violent I think it's the Dominion we
think they're back I'm sure you manually
exit for Tarsus I don't think so I think
to get to open-world now you got to go
delay but I just started thought I don't
know I do
so do you want meet you guys don't want
me to skip cutscenes right oh you is not
well-known my ward johnny was there 10
years ago she saw it with her own eyes
oh nice Johnny Rodgers yeah I was
Freitas being conservative question
ancient as Nick's Tube mentions yes but
most important it held the largest and
greatest enclave of freelancers anywhere
the freelancers along with the Sentinels
guardians of the Wolves protected free
mark and its people from the chaos of
our world until one day the Dominion
arrived on their doorstep cruel
conquerors from the yeah dark vipers
sniper FPS Wars only on the 22nd you can
play xbox for 10 hours today
with the access program and then get PC
and you just have it there's no like if
you have premiere a quest each group
earns in their own right to the
legendary general Tarsus and I believe
so goes eight seven six but I think you
only get ten hours what is this what's
this in the demo I can't remember your
like this wasn't a demo maybe not oh
damn there's way more feels kind of bad
for the arguments actually they got like
my javelins he came to take the city at
any cost
if you watch the cutscenes let me really
catch up oh nice Ben yeah we can
definitely
but the walls of the great Freemont did
not hold the dominion poured atoms with
many freelancers made their last stand
outside the city walls
a lot of people saying Xbox not wearing
like John sorry that stay about when
without warning the Doom sentinels fell
back
I'm not seeing that monster that deep in
the city
Johnny discovered what the sentence
already the domain Ian didn't want to
destroy free mark they wanted to capture
an ancient shaper relic that was
protected deep inside the city the
Senate
it seems this dr. Harkin believed he had
created a way for the Dominion to use
the Cenotaph to control the anthem of
creation itself
[Music]
arrogance
[Music]
the anthem will
the terrible Cataclysm which was
unleashed that day destroyed free mark
destroyed the Dominion destroyed
everything I know your alpha-beta does
not care to ilysm became the heart of
Rage some survived to tell the story of
free mark but not many Dominion must be
back for a reason
I clearly have more Intel to hunt down
come and find me later yeah me too
I'll contact you when I have something
okay
for those asking about Xbox and how to
get it to work I do not know how to get
that to work right now unfortunately let
me read some stuff hearing exists the
factions doesn't it okay I say that only
because I'm on PC right now so I can't
really help you
unfortunately I apologize I hope that
you eventually get in will you stream re
to go survivors you'll see probably not
today we have a metro stream at 11:30 so
I'll probably be getting out of here by
like 10:30 11:00 just so people know
also you're locked to your second weapon
until level 3 of which will take this
sniper I guess kind of like
they will keep the Scout she still don't
have a support seal or components take
our little three lightning level up but
I don't think it's worth it I think
frost shards are too good I could change
my appearance but I'm not going to deal
with that right now
hmm I can't get in on PC yeah I think a
lot of people are probably trying to get
on right now and I was able to get on
earlier as mentioned earlier because I
have a review coffee in terms of the
review climate ass are we doing review
in progress I believe so I believe there
will be a review progress for like maybe
the weekend or something like that and
then like more before review next week
names Prospero you understand being a
freelance is more than just a job it's
about pride doing something well pride
in your job intolerable what's the
charge into a fight looking plain and
simple
rapid Quran that's too early for me to
tell I enjoyed it
when I played the demo but I enjoyed
leader shooters much about it colorful
it's what I do
when lances want to make a statement
prices for scale up the store for you
guys and decals or body work I'm the guy
they come to we're used to hasn't been
any demand the force can't even build
anything these days I'm hoping you can
change that how can I help ya I wouldn't
be shocked the people took a day off and
have Monday off a member and someone
with the guts to collect it if you can
find some on back in business
we both are I'll teach you how to craft
things okay all right what I wanted to
hear you all need to search for Ember
outside the fort bring it here because
like getting this place back on its feet
well do all right
so he helps craft that guy was not in
the demo outlaws unlocked see I can fold
the store here's my coins
so you either spend sixty one thousand
coins or eight hundred fifty shards and
I'm guessing every one hundred shards is
about a dollar so it's not twenty bucks
anymore looks like it's eight fifty
maybe three eight
I bought everything and it's not working
is it ps4 though like I mean sorry Xbox
one I don't know you got you you have to
also realize it's day one of where a lot
of people are probably trying to get in
and that is definitely gonna be tough
wait what am i doing right now I gotta
click three pieces of amber so I got to
do call how to unlock the n7 armor that
I'm not sure Aquarius so we got to do
free play I don't really want to do hard
right now oh they changed the percentage
too so I recommended for players who
want more of a challenging experience a
mix of teamwork and skills recommended
enemy health and damage is increased by
52% but you don't gain more Lu what all
right so you have masterwork drop here
so basically there's no reason to
actually do hard then because what am i
benefiting from I thought there was like
drop rates I could have sworn on demo
that hardmode head drop away drop rate
buffs apologies if it's not working for
someone y'all glad you're here
appreciate it
I'm gonna really quickly eat a banana
off-screen because I need something some
sort of form or substance to last the
next three hours
I'm playing in the US but again as
mentioned I'm on a review copy version
I understand it's frustrating and I'm
sure if I was in loading screen hell I'd
be equally as frustrated they did
eventually sort it out at least with the
demo so there's promise that they can
sort it out for this to as I add the
microtransactions are all cosmetic based
so as you saw there you can still you
can still buy it with gold somehow I
have a crude forty thousand gold from
just doing three or four missions and it
was like 61 thousand gold to buy those
skins so I don't think it's like that
difficult to get it but you never know I
think that I think the difficulty on
normal should be fine are there's other
players already in here so they've
probably caught up or done more than I
have yeah so we just got to find some
embers
very much what you guys played the demo
then you know where we're at
find some embers no idea what level
these guys are I will say some people
were saying in the office that they're
seeing level 20s or 30s maybe if I had
time to go ham I would have could you
put the platform you're using in the
title uh yeah Ben can you do that for me
philanthropy if you have a second if not
I guess
[Music]
guess we're exploring
usually embers come from killing the
stuff or farming materials I'm sorry I
guess at least you can hang out and I
was just asking if you could add VC to
the title so that uh oh I just got the
audio thing sick what just happened I
guess it's okay that I didn't get booted
but I don't literally know what just
happened
best javelin place storm question mark
ah I like storm Ranger and interceptor I
did not have a fun time personally with
Colossus
I feel like Colossus could be better
down the road but I don't know hard to
say
we saw loot chests in the demo yeah
there's definitely we loot chests in the
open world I found some during the demo
was so loading screens man oh I got
kicked I got kicked out of the open
world but not out of the game however I
have lost audio so the audio issue still
exists so I'm gonna risk it I'm gonna
risk it
I can't do this without audio so I just
killed the game real quick or attempted
to kill the game I should actually you
know what don't all that for ever like I
just did
you'll you'd want to UM crap you'd want
to task manager I should have had task
manager up no it's it's back here in a
second hold on it that audio bug was in
the demo too so if you lose audio you
have to close the game out and open it
again
a Hinch dream is also frozen sick well
see if we get back in that could have
been a huge mistake to be honest
loading screams still seem out of
control
yeah there's still a thing over under on
audio thing happening during the stream
already just happened zippy you can
count that number one I really hope I
don't get loading screen simulator
alright no we're good task managers my
best friend
yeah it is when playing anthem if you
played the demo at all task manager was
my number one baby cuz the I haven't got
the loading screen bug but when I did
get loading screen I a task manager
doubt of it I was like the only way I
guess not Mak sufficient you just saw
that I got the audio bug which is
unfortunate but yeah
how song hi I'm Mouse dude I actually
wine gums I've tried it and I can't play
this game mouse keyboard not because of
the shooting I think that third-person
shooting is part of its fine but the
flying part of it I just can't handle on
mouse keyboards so I I'm playing on
controller who's keeping him running
tally of these who starts you totally
can max efficient that's number one you
know should get a counter for how many
times it breaks huh sure maybe what's up
mr. H devil face I think even if people
can are can do their best to prep their
servers nothing day one ever works the
way you think it should even Blizzard
who is renowned for you know online
gaming struggled with WoW and other
things you know so it's not shocking
that like other people like have
problems with connectivity and stuff
like that for for a large audience at
least on day one usually things work
themselves out you know
how am i liking it so far I mean I like
the sci-fi aesthetic the shooting feels
good I wouldn't say it's great
I think Destiny's still the best shooter
out there an outlaw game that needs
dealing ok well we're back and we have
audio which is good Trey Julius I do
agree that it was probably risky of me
to leave but I wasn't gonna have you
guys sit there and watch me play and we
might not have audio
it sounds like when there's a bunch of
other people that are also having
problems getting on PC right now
we got to find some embers oh those are
new
we gotta have a sniper come on in for me
that's not a number winner how long it
takes to get three embers or I just
don't know where to go
oh that's way too high on that the
Lightning's a little weird sometimes
with uh I do like a man
oh there's an item that's still good
though it's like that RPG life you know
day one living that green life then blue
life and purple life okay I'm gonna go a
Brook oh pretty ham this weekend
probably sorry Corinne if your song the
cat fiance was in chat earlier I kind of
like tell that to my apex legends buddy
that I play with every now and then I
can see it was like hey I'm so sorry but
uh I'm gonna be on anthem this at least
it's a three-day weekend but you never
know I might hop on ask them here and
there because it's like Oh big boy
because there's no pvp anthem so
dude I pressed r1 l1 we will talk to
compile that's at destiny oh shoot I'm
missing him whoops
sorry I was like spam this was my dad
this game looks wicked
yeah like aesthetically I think it's
awesome the gun sounds feel good
you get an angle on this time mean boy
right now
diapers are pretty good just so you know
all right that's the other thing I'm
gonna have to like really remember and I
made fun of Aaron okay
chat I need you every time you see me
melee and I clearly didn't mean to melee
like that time I clearly did right but
every time you see me melee and I didn't
mean to melee I need you to press up
like that because that's me bailing
weapon swap in all honesty and it
definitely doesn't help that I just I've
been like playing the crap out of Apex
so if you see me like randomly melee
it's literally because serious it's
mainly because I am hitting switch herb
I'm thinking why is switching because
that's what switches in most games yeah
I literally doesn't get harder just more
damaging bullet playing yes but that
makes it harder to be honest like I had
to play way safer just now on a part but
the problem is I don't see why someone
would play hard unless they really golly
gosh I'm doing a tea pose now I guess Oh
are we back please tell me we're back
I'm getting hit that's what it is it's
the bird it's that bird that I was
shooting that I couldn't kill
you know what I'm okay with it I'm okay
with it I'd rather I'd rather them I'd
rather them give me that that delay that
lag delay and then not kick me out I'm
okay with this I mean I'm not happy
about it but I'm okay with it
you know what I mean like we got a trade
off of something
Oh anyway it's back to my point about
hard in from the demo and and someone
can in check him kind of confirm or deny
or help me figure out if I'm right or
wrong I'm pretty sure it was with on
hard mode on the demo rap if you played
hard I feel like it was a like a reward
bonus for it okay
later Sonali turtle thanks for stopping
by
oh it did hit him Wow okay just don't
doubt I guess I am not finding embers
right now but oh no what did I do that
yeah there was increased loot drops were
hard okay maybe it's like something we
have to get access to but like right now
like early in this game like after three
or four missions or whatever that I want
like I have not
there's no as as a stand to be picked
hard there's no oh there you go there's
no benefit for playing hard so yeah
how's it run on Xbox do not know never
played on on Xbox to be honest
is that auto-lock a feature are you
talking about like how I'm walking or
like are you talking about the lightning
are you talking about something else or
the cross
[Music]
Frosch ours kind of home that's what
you're asking about
those guys I remember were real pieces
of crap they heard it they heard so bad
they heard it English hard
[Music]
I can't freeze them no press app
what's his crit
I might die yep that's my fault
I was about to alt and I did the r1 l1
again oh boy oh that's you that they put
you in back right away
yes that's good yeah yeah f my Hawaii
all right back to this like I'm a man oh
my god they're all dead
I revive you help me interesting how
they all I guess it's like every element
going off maybe that's why it's
that low
okay got a common item up there huh kind
of missed the Rangers like double Joe he
actually have to unlock the Ranger by
the way what
yeah the Lightning is like one of the
coolest looking abilities by far am i
even getting hit from was that really
just from those those three guys that's
so bad
I regret using my all time have it the
bill dude now because there's a shield
boy
the blinks really cool do though that
the storm has
you need to get to that Sentinel
sentinels in bad shape they need your
help
housing at the moment by the way the
other
these sentinels man I think I'm gonna
like the Colossus posterior oh yeah you
should try it I it's not what you think
though at least not to start oh here let
me help you out there
try hover more for bonus shield yeah I
need to get used to that good shout
though
powerful stars closing fast best of luck
[Music]
ah the floating was not a good idea I
saw on fire no crap you guys like can't
find a way to not
the cipher feels guilty though well
fools
oh my kind of a lot to clear out
I'm a sniper out
nope
that's not Browns it is
let's go get some of our meat shields
here now they came back what the other
thing I'm not even sure of is like
I don't know if you get like xp for
killing stuff it's more for like combos
and finishing stuff I'm already on the
next part all right
please be fun oh the commentary is here
are you talking about like the chat or
me oh wow that's a lot of material I
wouldn't say the bullet spongey it's
more about convoying it's not
necessarily just about the shoot at
shooting program where like if you do
you know proper primers and tombos do
way more damage
[Music]
also like yeah you have a different
dynamic when you have a team versus like
solo - oh yeah and put the hover
a level-3 join me
make sure you through the same level
like
the bailout that big boy yet so your
alternate also gives you school life
back so in a pinch I'm worried I'm doing
something wrong that's what I'm going to
do crash
and of course as I do that another big
boy hey what are you going to do right
yeah
did it again Wow
45 chimeric alloy all right
guess they don't skimp on cracking parts
Oh
there's a lot of ways
oh you know what I must be doing
something wrong it's a search for
explosives
[Music]
all right let's see the hoard of
supplies you know that moment when you
realize like I think they're never gonna
stop spawning
feels like that right chat am i doing
something wrong I feel like they're not
the spawns are not stopping which leads
me to believe I'm not doing something
right
I can also just leave this to buzz
there's any like well I mean I'm
guessing there's XP if I finish it
that's a chest and we've got another
uncommon ember which is good
I know I need to collect pieces but it
says search for explosives I know what
my main mission one is I'm talking about
the purple old mission right now like
there's a I have like another sub
mission if you see you are talking about
and it says search for explosives I mean
there's these things but those are like
mines or not I'm clearly missing
something I feel like well let's follow
the little sonar which I guess I should
always be doing
that when I get closer it's not that way
and this is a gesture you thought that
popper if I won't fly away
I like I'm so confused right now up
maybe try that
it gets up there
just in front of me
all right I don't know we're just gonna
go get another ember this is taking too
long I clearly do not know what I'm
doing there sadly
look Foursquare crates I did look for
trades I shot like a rectangle one that
did nothing
the mines are back you know like I shot
all of them earlier bro square crates
man I'm I'm literally looking for square
grades although now we have some
teammates anyways so era let's see what
the let's see if these guys figure it
out
Center the squad of three
[Music]
it's in the water up someone found it
behind the column this one picked up the
but the one has now picked it up and
needs a plan B so I clearly just didn't
know where the thing is so we're good
now that's the power of the community
I'm sorry that it triggered I didn't
play this one I barely played the free
the free roam stuff and the demo just
because one it crashed a lot for me and
two I just did stronghold and visitors
way more loot
I felt like but maybe since I didn't
finish one of these maybe that's why
yeah I don't worry
they got me so there's this Emine thing
and there's the cash to kill it
get clear
okay
all right world event complete thing
this is the only way out
oh maybe no whatever we cleared it it's
over with let's go find a number I
thought I was gonna like storm I was
wrong yeah I don't know I think like out
of all the classes I played I think I
had the most fun personally on
interceptor so maybe I should have
unlocked interceptor curse loading
screams after this mission we go to
Tarsus I mean yeah I probably have to go
back to Tarsus yeah thank you guys and
gals all for tuning in to the like
premiere access get the chest uh-oh
mistakes were made
uh whatever cuz I never saw the test it
won't hurt that bad to like know that I
might have lost the test it's not a big
deal
whatever
I just want this last ember sometimes
just a negative at the end ah thank you
Ron Swanson I appreciate your patience
in the matter
ah and the tips I appreciate all the
tips coming in - sorry if I'm seeing
them late
it happens grab that's hurry
oh no it's just a big tank guy I want to
ping this target for the legs
how did I hurt him just now
Oh war artillery
this is happening
hey we did it brings sweet screens we
need to find like a chest somewhere look
at this last number
as I get distracted
on Eric it's like Dark Souls with guns
oh how about that but sure if you want
to make that comparison [ __ ] looks too
easy I have it on normal Joseph if you
want it if you want a more difficult
experience you could put it on hard but
since there's no oh there we go
since there's no actual like benefit to
putting it on heart oh wow we just hit
the mother lode the mother lode you know
that stuff why don't we just find this
spot earlier so we just got 2000 coins
and I think one of those like purple
coins so now we can return to Fort chars
this oh right it's extra free play all
right it's definitely not dark souls
with guns I am looking forward to sucky
row though on that note I appreciate
everyone's patience this morning as I
wake up still waiting i I'm so excited
to have a cup of coffee you know a
little bit
is this a beta or early-access this is
if you have premier origin premiere like
the subscription then you have access
early access to the game essentially we
can play it early
so I should be like level 4 right thank
goodness who are component slots
unlocked we got some greens
we got glacial spear that sounds good
that sounds very good for charts this
please I guess I could work forge any
microtransactions in this game yes
they're cosmetic though dilmer says Mass
Effect + Dragon Age + destiny equals
anthem yeah that's that's fair I think
Oh see neon javelins 2 8 16 and 26 what
are the thoughts on this game I'm
enjoying it
I'm curious sorry I've watched like
their version of what the endgame video
is I'm like curious what that's gonna
look like that's my biggest curiosity
possibly concerned but you know I'm not
there yet so I can't really say but I do
enjoy it I think the the primer and
combo system is cool primer detonator
system is cool you know aesthetically I
like the wait was this this one gives me
shield I guess we'll take the shield
alright the next one's at 6 so not too
far off we can try some different blast
seals
I think our explosion
even through walls that's pretty cool
slow recharge though there which I Flame
Burst and I think we have glacial spear
now well level six glacial spear well we
can destroy some of this to this stuff
we don't need extras oh and got some
weapons take the sky rifle I think break
some of this stuff down real quick the
endless no loading screens are no no I
mean I could see the concern with that I
wasn't a huge fan of it either to be
honest but so we can either increase our
level or keep the sniper we probably
just keep the sniper I think not worried
about my appearance right now I think I
look good
leaving flame is super bad yeah I I
think it I think when I use it I was
like oh it looks cool but it probably is
not that good is Flame Burst any good
taco or should I just keep lightning
because I know lightnings pretty good
all right let's get to business and fire
up the forge it's time all these
javelins around here it's got the tender
loving care they deserve
head on over to the forge and you can
start crafting but don't forget when you
want to make a statement
maybe polish that javelin up with a nice
coat of pain and thunder
hey the best freelance has always
arrived with a bang but first they buy
it from me don't be a stranger that's
how it goes John John Bosco though like
for all the people that watch and
complain that's kind of like what the
internet like well like that's what
people do on the internet I guess sweet
don't really know you do we have skill
trees not a traditional school tree no
that's fine
my job is to keep I can't change my
abilities with a group of smugglers in
the area who are they like I said before
I'm betting Dominion which means
troubles coming our way big trouble if
you're right waiting's bracelet yeah I
agree
start by meeting my agent had a
regulator camp here learn what else she
knows and go from there we'll get it
done
lightnings presold yeah I'll just try
something different just to try it all
right we're going back out there
level four how are you enjoying I like I
like it so far
I mean again I said I like the sci-fi
shooter elements to it I guess we're
trying the incursion so why not oops
should just
we don't have consumables unlockable yet
either miss Tori any good I think it's
too early for me to tell Ken we haven't
done enough I haven't got through enough
I like grinding but I wasn't expecting
this to be an MMO I wanted a better Mass
Effect game well if you like grinding
though I don't know I feel like this is
gonna have that den says I think people
already have a negative outlook it is EA
after all yeah but you know what
surprisingly I don't I don't know how
many people in chat up late apex legends
but that's assault game and that's an EA
game how's the currency seems fine I'm
not even sure how I got to 40,000 gold
neil to be honest I should have checked
that sooner but if you wanted a cosmetic
skin it's like 60 something thousand
gold and then if you wanted to buy
shards which is like microtransactions I
think it's like 850 or something like
that
is the map full of loading screen in
certain areas I mean in that last area
it was very similar to the demo where if
I went into a cave it definitely was
like loading another place I don't know
though the one thing that kind of gets
me are these loading screens though can
you choose which javelin at level 2 you
can tow with a group we all storms it's
not $20 case it's like 850 you start
with 40k okay gotcha I'm not like that
concerned about 5 or 10 seconds because
I'm probably the only beautiful looking
world though
okay you don't father the regulator camp
should be coming up soon keep an eye on
mr. see the edge of Scots hair tree
where are these loading speed so long
all right we're gonna try playing birth
oh wow really a lot farther than I
thought it would Colossus
search for a clue I cut up to UK oh nice
yeah I wasn't very far I should not have
picked hard earlier that ruined me I'm
not sure rise if I saw my face since I
picked my character face then we can
just join up next to machine or
something
we chose fear oh that's not as good at
that
but because I sharted sets up so well oh
we got the flamethrower already though
that's it that's a good move
like Colossus is really good for
clearing on a bunch of tiny ads there's
no doubt about that
oh I miss
how important is flying in the game they
look pulled me through use it quite a
bit to like - wrong way use it quite a
bit to traverse get away from stuff very
important
yeah fire now yeah I switched to fire
ability and then also I have a different
ice ability loading screens yeah yeah
juicer yeah it's the as I mentioned it's
kind of the unfortunate reality should
definitely play the game getting
informed idea you know you can even get
I mean I know people don't want to give
more money necessarily but you can try
this on PC for $15 and your monthly
subscription if you want do you get the
whole game this is the whole game
thank you
all right more quite suppression huh
and then if you go through a waterfall
it cool your jets sometimes the truth
hurts
I I don't know what do you mean yeah man
no not relax our dangerous that Lara
Croft it me never know
Oh pity for you oh it's like Palpatine
bastard
oh there's our buddy dude this guy's a
badass
sure it's like the shredder yeah all
right let's kill some stuff
let's run into a wall even you're
sitting in a chair somewhere
I gotta find some stuff about how Blake
not used to having professional shoes I
guess like this she's the life it was
what
pretty sure she did there are some
dialogue leave the hideouts catch the
monitor his name is the monitor mine
does feel good wood controller except
for when you crash fire firmly turned
off
wait losing it you need to stay in range
so depending on filet
I'm pretty serious of exhume watch
yourself
smile become sir
hurry he's gonna hit start
Anthony to have a rave until next year
well they they never said they were
gonna have a raid though they said that
they were just gonna have activities
that like give you that raid like
activity but not call it a raid whom to
choose is ready ranger good while you
unlock at two six eighteen and twenty
six so you're gonna get them all my
least favorite personally is the
Colossus personally gunplay looks
somewhat slow
[Music]
so let it rip
keep it up
[Music]
where's the monitor checking
[Music]
what do you want to take that out see
you getting a bad feeling here I think
maybe this was an ambush they led us
here breathing
he's obviously more powerful than you I
think it's important to take a measure
freelancers boast of courage they never
have it's more extinct all right we did
it
uh yeah well yeah GameSpot irfan I just
want to say once again thank you to
everyone that's hanging out chatting
appreciate it I know there's some
saltiness in chat but
either way I appreciate being from
opinions and all that fun stuff
[Music]
I was a scrub wasn't as good as the PCBs
yes and then get as many badges any bugs
I had the audio bug earlier oh I got a
gear slot I'm lost
I think that's consumables that's a
level 5 we're gonna get the Lightning
back and maybe even for all shards to be
honest wait what why my matchmaking I
should be going to Tarsus
uh Judah I have not tried on the Oski
where I just know that I did not like
flying on mouse keyboard when I am
played the first time personalization on
this looks legit though yeah I mean you
can customize your javelin pretty sweet
but I did show the store res things are
eight fifty not 20 or it's 850 shards
instead of whatever the other number was
I think in the past we were saying 2500
here you go here's the launch Bay okay
this is where I'll see a ton of javelins
probably launch Bay kiosks contracts for
personal vault okay Monterey featured
store all right here's the social space
I suppose that's where you see everyone
was this vanity store let's look at the
vanity store I already did this didn't I
I totally did how he can buy crafting
materials with our coins that's cool
this is free I'll take that sure I have
the Legion of Don stuff too
I mean that that's free I'll take
anything that's free oh I'll pre-order
item stuff can I claim this ready oh I
did
origin access items yep sure
all right so that was that I'm guessing
is that back to Tarsus back to activate
the forge shake I guess that's just
forge all right we got our support seal
which is pretty important wind wall
didn't unlock a second thing yet though
whoa oh you just get a level 18 do we
use it
chat do we use the level 18 I guess so
you get a recharge on shields for
emptying your mag sure not a really big
fan of the Glacial spear I'm just gonna
take the frost shards back and I wasn't
a huge fan of Flame Burst either my
lightning back okay we can mess around
with or our look I guess we got the
Legion of Don helmet all right sure you
just go full Legion of dawn sure why not
guys probably don't want to look at
customization though huh we should
probably split a game alright that's
that's fine I should try to find Ben
Tarsus
I sound like I'm dead yeah I'm sorry I
didn't get too much sleep I don't think
I'm I don't I don't think I sound that
dead but I guess I'll take care your
comment to heart just joins how's it
looking so far it's been fun so far for
me I got the audio body Oh bug once so I
guess okay so that's where that is
all right why can't I run darcet cool
loading screens bro yeah
how much for shards um I didn't check
but I'm guessing it's about $1 per
hundred we have no idea maybe you need
coffee she possibly tore the place apart
you bet they'll do expansion well
Spencer they have like a Content plan
already and I don't think I'm sorry
there's like there's like chapter 1
chapter 2 chapter 3 chapter 1 starts and
marchers and like that sheep is for
shards and 5gs you can get by ones in
charge yeah so skins about it I need
another banana they have set their
sights on for Tarsus right well the
force isn't exactly my idea of living
the dream but it is home and I prefer it
to remain dictator free what can we do
for now remain patient I don't want to
make a move until I have more
information in the meantime there's
someone I'd like you to meet Sentinel
Bryn she's sharp trustworthy and could
use some assistance why don't you help
her while I look into the Dominion I'll
be in touch Sentinel Rissa brain fort
commander Sentinel how can we help
well we probably shouldn't talk here
come see me by my desk and my plants
bombs right so uh good I will see you
okay then my character kind of looks
like that character The Sentinel my new
friend you listened well to my story of
free marker
ever heard it told like that I was long
retired the battle was not mine to fight
what good friends tell me I was a
freelancer for many years
you know what freelancers do we deal
with things beyond the wall problems
about 850 truck we can also buy within
cases we save lives you hear me okay I
hear you
people could count on us in this world a
big deal but that has been lost people
don't trust us hard times now but enough
gloom got a contract for you going to
protect some Arcanist doing seismic
tests okay seismic tests yeah check to
see if there's a contract is this wrong
foundation don't want it to fall into a
hole like last time what but these tests
attract animals the kind with teeth you
know you protect one side of the fort
and freelancer right will protect the
other you hear me I hear you good I'm
hungry no breakfast now go see that's me
now go I am hungry no breakfast yet
that's me 100% right now right no is it
because I I engaged in that contract
that I'm not gonna do story now should I
just get rid of it can't get rid of it
yeah that's why me to go there
how do i mmm rack
I should have alright well we're doing
this contract
what's my daily trials I already did it
what's my weekly trial
I need 18 more missions okay you got it
you got it
there's a bunch of Kodak court codecs
coach Danks can't offer streaming early
I'll appreciate the kind words and thank
you for tuning in
all right there's my legion of don storm
I guess we're doing a contract sorry Ben
if you're not on this contract sure oops
launch it what other big games first
half of this year can't remember any
apart from days gone well there's five
today there's jump horse Metro Exodus
crackdown 3 anthem far cry new dawn
that's and then next month you have
division three sec euro DMC five
yeah I'm sure as I kind of agree I'm
surprised that there wasn't a character
creator and that you could only pick
from preset phases maybe you don't end
up seeing your face too often so kind of
doesn't matter yeah that's what Lucas
said I bet it's mainly because of that
[Music]
[Music]
actually don't think I have your own
origin oh it's you ITA why too
patching it free love together here
let's see if we can keep the market to
survive yes
freelancer right that's begun our Patrol
this is right
because I wasn't the only one to pick up
the contract
oh yeah I left alive as well at the
disco and then today there's actually a
free what Resident Evil 2 survivors DLC
I think
[Music]
[Applause]
they died to pass
but not okay I will make sure these are
kids get back
okay you're crafting materials never
know
so it's not it yes I see okay let's do a
search for energy signatures in the area
look there's bad guys
the one thing about the lightning that
keeps going up
not have a problem
free them nobody's good scars must have
taken my white a carcass
yes go stars scavenge everything yeah
so I energy signature Arcanist tools
crafting the jail's probably irrelevant
but you never know this is the storm
traveling right yes correct
oh I can't see if I'm gonna overheat
I actually haven't seen that many
interceptors a lot of storm Colossus so
far that the Legion is on skin yeah put
it on because we are happening we grab
it from the van in store
this thing is magic well hello
jump more jump was already dead this is
like a low-level contract that I wasn't
supposed to do at this level
destiny gunplay is way better but also
first-person that's Anthony's abilities
look better yeah I mean I like the
shooting and destiny more like you just
said but definitely the abilities are
cool and learning the combos is gonna be
a big thing primers that Nana
are these not the artists
there you go you're okay our conditions
are safe only cuts and greases call the
sentinels to pick them up already done
good nothing more check on freelancer
right got it
right you see these stars in your area
that's alright
yeah I don't think I like the assault
rifle personally
yeah the game is always gonna look
better on your screen that seeing it
online
never get this close to four Tarsus
before I can get to them
I'm finally normal but that's mainly
again because there's just no reason to
play on hard because you don't benefit
from good pleasures no increase like
rocks
I'm not gonna play hard just
a lot of scar bodies over here away from
the campsite
no not like this
Chad did you just jinx me okay we didn't
we beat it okay that would have been
kind of sketch the last time I was able
to reconnect to the expedition so it was
fine thank you guys all again for tuning
in to GameSpot live
all right we hit six that means I
unlocked another javelin and we got a
new ice inscription that's cool and a
storm combo Wow in combo more okay
let's go to the forge our loading times
out there's still kind of not so great
to be honest when will the reviews be
out probably later maybe next week or
something depending on how crazy or how
fast somebody goes maybe
I'm almost out of the mission you were
in ok the contract one okay
all right so I never I need to go talk
well there's a couple things I guess I'm
gonna go talk to yarrow
we gotta go talk to the Sentinel plant
lady with the people want to believe
freelancers out there box light of
Legion it's a gun that they comes with
the John Allegiant attack of course she
knows I would be angry to write her
story for the wall but my young friend
she is alive this is a good story to
tell people will hear of it
think that'll help around here oh yes
now rife is recovering at the bar if you
want to check on her I will keep an eye
out for contracts never fear
uh yeah Johnny I think you got to walk
through the hub IRA for Tarsus all right
so where is that lady I was supposed to
talk to you okay so if I go straight I
can get to her I think
so we got a shopping list
so in here don't wear the wrong way I
think this is where Matthias is all
right
oh there's multiple missions there you
can just to my savior and the recent
scars aren't feasting on my liver right
this minute
bloody scars the spike in their
activities really thrown off my research
what are you working on exactly I'm
looking for a lost arcanist text known
as the elysian manuscript it was
inscribed by early members of our order
and has been lost for Jim I think you
can subscribe to it if they want let's
predict the behavior of 15 a month I
think or a blender you will create fire
storms or scorpions and I mean I can
show you the every little piece of
knowledge we can scrape together helps
you're making progress the heroic work
done by my assistants may they continue
to seek answers beyond this life led to
a discovery turns out that was a far
more ingenious way to pass knowledge
along invisible runes runes
yes how do i ha I picked you curiosity
you'll just have to continue on this
adventure to find out won't you my our
research has revealed a potential site
that may answer our questions just buy
me in the right direction they've used
this arcanist guy already what Ben I
need you to do this one I guess if you
can end up choosing different missions
the matthias one can't even get it to
boot so sander yeah well keep trying
you'll get in oh I can show this we're
on a 1080p monitor so obviously it's
gonna be 1080p I think I'm only on high
right now but yeah yeah I said it's a
high it's a nice set I'm running on i7
7700 okay with 1070 I think I could
probably bump it to ultra but it's just
risky
sometimes so it's gonna be the worst
thing you know
see if we can find Ben
excuse me I have two javelins there is
this show he probably doesn't show you
your actual like friends list though huh
hold on one sec guys
I don't know your handle been a
philanthropy X can you grab more than
one quest Oh Ben I need you to add me on
thing I'm gonna tell you what it is in a
second let's see if I can grab all the
other missions by talking to people oh I
don't know if you can trigger another
quest or another mission rather cuz
there's a contract I don't have another
oh wait no that's that's what I would
just pulled
yeah I just got talked everyone really
doesn't give you like an actual mission
prompt that seems kind of strange all
right you'll have some chats I guess
just came from here this is probably bad
idea to come this way um I haven't had
that much lag stutter but I did have a
couple of those like drop lost audio
kicks what's going on
you scare me a little sometimes do I
actually I suppose that's fair I do
pedal in danger
still you should know me better than
that I know you okay
trick question you don't worry
liberating birthdays oh of course I do
bro what kind of monster doesn't like
celebrating my birthday
exactly and yours is why don't you run I
can't not telling but I appreciate the
thought and gift nice try
you're not telling so I'm not gifting
actually the day we met it's my birthday
now that is a trick which time recently
Maurice added me so after about against
a time you kicked my pocket well I was
stopping aboard moldboard why is that
which horror show actually how can i
enhance your experience you always
looking for trouble is that what made
you want to be a freelancer do you think
ship this and to you it's fun and the
facts a rope I like to think of it more
because the haunts of I don't yeah cheer
off there's no mission for that dang it
been you baited me hold on feel like I
got you baited
like big-time jebaited well what the
hell okay
all right here let's try talking this
guy to you real answer thanks again for
your help business is already looking up
selling the Thunder huh
hey people laugh but the uniform makes
the soldier ever seen the Dominion too
soon for me to give you my thoughts
about the game isn't Asian is half the
battle
like it's literally been what two hours
I like the skills I like the combo
system
I think the shootings okay I personally
don't care for story I only play per
Lutz I need to get basically I want
people to your enemies will show the
giant gone I'm all part of the
presentation
bullets tend to settle things pretty
this is just like loyalty not even
alright thanks and ready to you it's
nice of you I clearly have a javelin bug
where have two javelins on the stand
all right let's get that in here
that work
hmm
literally hitting a right now
try this one more time she doesn't work
I'm probably just gonna load the mission
again do anything up did it finally do
it okay I just had to spam the crap out
of it I hate it three times whoops sorry
about that just waiting for players see
how this goes all right he's in sweet
we're launching our the screen prices
they're about 850 give or take not $20
not like it was previously
and the other thing if you're asking me
in terms of my impressions the other
thing I don't enjoy really is all these
loading screens I think it's kind of
crazy that there is like this much load
in between playing and the one that like
really blows my mind is you know when
you're kind of immersed in action and in
a world and then you go into a cave but
then you have to load into the cave even
at least those
and he's hard to top they the map is too
because I feel like there's pie a lot of
like underneath the surface stuff to
make it bigger than it actually is
I guess I'm not caves and stuff
we are
[Applause]
creatures know who cares about cakes
yeah a peer assessment
Oh also the other thing that kind of
bought was my mind ooh is for a lute
game to have it where you don't actually
get the loot till your app out of it it
seems kind of crazy to me - oh crap I
forgot I could unlock a new javelin I
shouldn't win and got the Interceptor we
got to do that after this that goes
that's weird radar says there's more
and he took it was chosen to make this
test difficult working with freelancers
of course how did you learn about these
immigrants we're looking for the moment
I realized that training for secrecy in
our history
they'd open up new ways so that the
research I already had
think you can hold up to like three
echoes at one time to be close
I think if we find those stories it'll
be like overwatch Dow
interacting
let's get those echoes oh yeah we're
like doing three things at one time
Chester
nice how did you do this work without
freelance or help slow I hear some
associate require many uncomfortable
nights in the jungle this book you're
looking for the Elysium manuscript right
Percy the truth the time twists hides it
the manuscripts window to a very
so looking for us there you go precisely
[Applause]
with the most broken slack
I don't think we're too early to tell
maybe I don't think it matters in the
beginning I switched between my squat oh
yeah I make sense to just to get
diversity per round almost like you
think of it as a kind of like monster
world where yourself a
[Music]
we did it with deadhead the real
audience is currently at school working
yeah sadly but it's a three day weekend
for some people which is cool I hope you
guys have a good weekend obviously
I think I'll grab the Colossus since I
forgot to use my own life yeah I forgot
to use my unlock so I'm gonna use it for
the Interceptor it's right to be cut
noctus it's probably because like battle
royale games can be entertaining for
viewers to watch and then each game can
be slightly different than the other you
know so that's probably why battles or
youtubers go crazy over battle Royales
and then there's a lot of people
probably playing battle Royales so
they're trying to like see what the pros
do or you know the better players do and
things like that
can you change out armor pieces or just
colors materials I was able to change
out armor pieces based off of like this
stuff like vanity stuff you get but yeah
oh right
so why should be able to unlock a new
javelin right what I thought it was at 6
probably the only thing in crowd there's
a scout because I leveled it so the
interesting thing about crafting [ __ ] I
should have let that menu play out for
you guys is to craft certain things you
have to actually do be challenges what's
this haste it affects nothing it's very
good
didn't get anything there
yeah and I've seen the unlock at all
yeah that's weird
cuz it shooted me at six so we gotta go
talk to Matthias our boy here yeah
there's other helmets and torsos yeah
Sean you might have to use like the
purple coins or whatever the different
currency did to actually get them though
kind of like the demo if you call
freelancer freelancer yes excellent
you're here
Matthias need something need something
oh no no no have something you remember
that strange energy the runes emitted I
remember you mentioning something while
I collected them I managed to isolate
and identify the energy pattern I passed
it along to your cypher who can now help
me find those invisible runes which are
the key to unlocking another
impenetrable mystery which means you
want me to go find more of them yes the
more the better with enough I'm certain
I can find the location of the Elysium
manuscript certain I've several leads
it's very promising talk later you got
it Matthias I'll talk later yeah mmm-hmm
all right
[Music]
well he's got contracts let's take a
look at the map there's another mission
over here so I guess we're gonna go do
that one it's over this way somewhere
maybe this is the plant lady it should
be on Xbox if you have the access but
you might only get 10 hours on Xbox with
the EA access oh there she is the plant
lady hello
Sentinel good to see you again isn't it
I don't associate much with freelancers
okay or anyone not a sentinel really
well I hope you don't regret getting to
know one of us yes me too okay alien if
you don't like the tone of the voice
then you can always pick I don't use to
be contracting house it runs bees no
Sloan for Tarsus it could be dangerous
if the scars get hold of it agreed I'll
check it out for you good I mean good
luck freelancer right no problem
all right then I picked up this mission
all righty
I think it you only run in the lab or
the launch Bay sorry the lab at least
you can bump up difficulty yeah
but I'm surprised that hard doesn't have
any type of bonus for actually doing it
on hard so like unless you want it to be
harder like inherently for yourself
there's not like you don't benefit from
it is what I'm saying is it running more
smoothly than the demo for me for the
most part yes I still got the audio
glitch though I have not got the 95
percent load bug though figure out
cheese rinse repeat on difficulty yeah
if you're just trying to get yeah if
you're trying to just farm loot but
that's what's gonna happen people are
gonna find a way to like beat the the
strongholds like really easily and like
with a certain strategy and then they're
gonna have to like figure out how to
patch that but the only lucky thing is
they don't have to worry about balancing
for PvP and so in that regard they can
like they don't have to worry like they
would in division right or destiny or
something like that but isn't there an
increase in rare drops for hard no not
not so far so that's why I'm playing on
normal
I was playing hard it was a bit it was
as it's hard okay if you played the demo
hard is actually feels harder than hard
on the demo like hard on like actual
launch is actually pretty hard and
there's no benefit so I'm definitely not
going to make my life harder if I'm not
getting any benefit for it
also the the drop rates stuff since
there isn't on hard you just have to
wait till you hit like GM or whatever
yeah you did get more for hard for sure
but when I looked at it there if you
unless I'm crazy because when you when
you bump it too hard in the demo you
would see that there was a percentage
increase I'm not okay obviously you
don't understand how this game works
then called Brico because the harder the
difficulty the higher the percentage
chance you then have to get loot it
literally says that in this so like the
reason you keep playing this game is
because there's grandmaster one
grandmaster 2 grandmaster 3 and each of
those give you a benefit I would play it
on hard mode if there was like a hey you
have like a 50% higher drop rate or
something but you know what what's the
point of that I mean sure I that's a
that's a complaint on a personal level
maybe that's subject to the fact that I
played the demo and the demo shouldn't
have told me if I played it on hard that
I would get more lose right like then I
probably wouldn't complain
maybe they just don't tell you well that
doesn't make sense because they tell you
for the other stuff and when I did do I
miss her too
it didn't feel like I was gaining that
much benefit out of it like I might drop
respect me
you get more XP in heart oh I didn't see
that
that's all that's another reason I would
add data to for XP but I didn't see that
as a option either
I would actually do harder for XP too
that's what was in Diablo
honey maybe there is but I didn't see it
we'll have to double-check
I stay low get that jet cooling
[Music]
scarred hey say would you say it loads
as well we're about to find out oh no it
does seems like flight controls are
smoother I feel like they're about the
same yeah get that Ember
oh wow sonic Ranger
what is the writing on the wall say this
hard mode no this is normal
almost pretty okay like I I was actually
well maybe hard with four people try
it's not as bad but I was getting pretty
wrecked and hard as a solo I gotta
freeze
like that
like that guy if that was hard and
probably
that's not good alright I get better at
anything that lightning
police tape my all like maybe you don't
matter in reality probably get it back
I've got those fragments
sweet
[Music]
the retail version training why thanks
for the hug from Brazil and we did it
mission completes our weekly we're
getting there 10 more missions for the
weekly can you play solo yeah
you also will natch make I've definitely
match makes a couple games
just skip this off
I ride most XP alright um gee he's back
not really any cool new skills that me
let's go to port artists too many
loading screens can you toggle off the
damaged numbers I'd have to check
actually I'm still used to damage
numbers optimist Rex who's gonna win
anthem or division to you
I think that's tough I think it depends
to write preference wise I think
division 2 has the Polish coming from
division 1 and learning a lot of things
and updating that game a whole bunch
kind of like how destiny did going in
investing to see any Colossus yes and
then the other way I look at it is you
want a realistic or more not realistic
like a military shooter or do you want a
sci-fi shooter so I think they're like
different in that regard
I played Division 2 beta like last week
and it kind of reminded me a little bit
about how much I kind of got I would get
upset a lot with the cover I like the
cover system
I just wasn't I know I wasn't doing a
good job personally but you know you get
stuck sometimes and I don't know I don't
think that's for me the movement of this
game and the open openness of the areas
is more my style I guess and not so much
like cover-based who sit ok he's he's
smoking I guess some people smoke like
that game spot you were about to
elaborate more about the Colossus
earlier that was the one I'm most
interested in
I will admit mostly because of aesthetic
so Kelson what's up on a personal level
I don't like the Colossus as much I'll
let this play through first Coulson I
will get back to that point though
heard from the regulator camp earlier
and we know why he's after unique shaper
relics doesn't mean he'll succeed did
you know the monitor was there when the
Dominion attacked free mark one of the
few who escaped when the Cenotaph
leveled the city
oh he's ruthless driven and savage an
incredibly powerful cipher and a
brilliant pilot he frightens even his
own people the storm will tear him apart
no one survives the heart of rage you
did yeah I did the Intel also reveals
and he's perfected a way to harness the
power of the Cenotaph and we cannot let
that happen
obviously I need you to find a way
through the heart of Rage get to the
Cenotaph first and silence it do what
freelancers do do it freelancers too
you're talking about bloody Cataclysm
he's right we aren't equipped to take
that on okay you can't tell good my
damage numbers thanks Chris well I can
think of others who survived the heart
of Rage that day who never let it go
studied it cetera sorted now I feel like
I'm supposed to know this one I all
Partners Halligan Fae Intel says the
monitor is on their trail suggests fate
has found something important last known
location oh I can
so how and failure Intel says your
partnership ended badly well thanks for
watching I'm sorry gave you for pulling
them out of that storm and failing where
are we going alright oh you're kidding
me
no Halleck and Fayette working with
princess sim the regulator boss oh
please she's a smuggler at best
she's a full-fledged crime lord at worse
we really need them to get through the
heart of rage and be the monitor to the
Cenotaph yeah we need him do we even eye
such a solid team already
that's my task Invictus you got my back
I got yours alright hey considering that
the monitor is both Lancer and cypher we
could probably use a very fabulous
cypher javelin pilot combo of our own oh
and be patient
pilot lessons are going fine but
seriously it might take you years damn
okay you know what this might be fun so
you need to get us something to get in
like News fighting could possibly
Orpheus Mouse well Oh already oh wait I
just do it from here that's pretty good
alright so let's look back at this so
hard right recommended for players who
want a more challenging combat
experience a mix of teamwork and skill
is recommended enemy health and damage
is increased by 52% so in the past in
the demo there was like a bonus drop
rate like this does right so enemy
health increase and damage by 165
percent increased masterwork drop chance
by one 64% so normal offer some bonuses
to loot at the cost of weight yeah
normal offer some bonuses to loot at the
cost of increased enemy health so maybe
there's a hidden like you get more loot
here but I wish it would say it like it
did in the demo
all right because easy offers easier
enemies but no bonuses to loot or XP
normal offers some bonuses to loot as a
cost of okay and then like so why would
the wording not say that for here we'll
do hard we'll see we'll see if it
matters oh shoot Ben has to accept that
we can try hard I just feel like it
would say it right like it clearly
states it here but it doesn't state it
here it doesn't say like hey you're
gonna get more loot or XP and I don't
know if that's just like a mistake but
it clearly does it for normal and it
clearly does it for easy so you think
the wording is just bad but but it was
in the demo that's what's like
mind-boggling to me sorry Ben
are you in a game now or something yeah
it's okay it's because I made it hard
mode or whatever so which could be
sketch to be honest we might die bunch
you think Green loot drops we'll see
you're not a normal player I thought
that too until this morning and I don't
know if it's because I I think I lost
you
oh okay I don't even know what just
happened there the dev sweetie you
should play hard for better loot did is
that like a recent tweet also in my mind
like I don't even think it matters in
that like over it
I don't think it matters in this
beginning stages if you actually get
better loot let's be real here right
like I don't think
better loot matters till your like 30 if
that makes sense right other than the
placebo effects because I don't know I
know how much is it actually helping you
you know losing taste squad today that
was just been I think Ben's like the
only one around where I am I guess oh
cool I have a connection problem alright
well we'll see how this goes if I can't
get back in I was roughly gonna stop
after this mission anyway so we'll see
the game didn't want me to play it on
hard basically
now it would a match made me read Hulk
well that's not good all right let's try
this really quick I'm gonna try killing
the game and coming back cuz I honestly
don't think the way it's going it's
actually gonna well let's see I have my
trusty task manager out I'll go back
we'll see if we get the arrow more time
oh no we got it in okay so Kelson sorry
i'm i spaced colossus talk right you
would think he's the Colossus would be
tanky but I feel that it's not that
tanky early to mid-game at least maybe
endgame when you have like crazy armor
and all that stuff it'll be more tanky
but Colossus feels more of a wants to
clear out you know all the you know like
small enemy waves and it can do it
quickly and efficiently and it needs to
because it needs to kill those things to
get health back because the Colossus
doesn't have a shield it it has a
literal shield but it doesn't have like
the blue bar shield that the other
javelins have so he doesn't it it barely
regains health if you get all the way
like low right so that makes it tough
because you're like thinking okay I
should be getting in and and kind of
being the I don't know if it's like
distraction or you know what I mean
you're kind of this you think in your
head you're gonna be the tank but then
it doesn't necessarily play that way so
I don't know I just didn't enjoy it also
you don't have a dodge as the Colossus
your dodge is the shield that I had
mentioned so yeah I may sit the last bit
out okay know where he's been I might
just do this last mission here or Walt's
not last mission but last mission on
stream and maybe we'll just do it on
we'll do it on hard as for science I
guess but I have a feeling I'm gonna die
a bunch
so well let's see hopefully we can't
squat it up with people otherwise it's
going to be pretty rough
yeah I don't know true justice we'll
have to see you never know though you
never know how those characters play at
level 30 but it does kind of suck though
if you think about it if you don't like
enjoy it um kind of playing through the
game as Colossus then that's kind of a
problem
Irv Irv uh says I had the same issue on
ps4 when switching the hardware oh it's
common oh okay Kelston the funny thing
is the Interceptor actually felt tankier
than the Colossus for me but that's
because the Interceptor wants to melee
and um things like that so it almost
gives you room for error that way I
guess how do you get the legendary armor
and wept from the pre-order they aren't
in rewards I got it from the Bandit II
store column if you're talking about the
Legion of Dawn's stuff
and the demo I found mods that health
regen the Colossus okay and there's one
other guy with me I haven't tried the
Colossus though in this version so I
could totally be wrong but that was my
experience from the demo
alright we got a full squad so I feel
better about that dang a level 9 am i
under a level for this or are those
people just doing kind of like quick
play missions stuff a lot of stuff to
harvest here ok now that guy's level
something to you I feel this bad now
loading screens step 45 seconds
I've never timed it actually but that
seems kind of bad if that's
maybe I shouldn't be here by myself
ah I just want to hit both and I didn't
still rawr
use your dodge one more I'll try
it is a cool ability though what I like
barely out of bounds right
[Music]
I mean you guys can tell me if you think
we're getting more greens I don't think
I think as long as I'm not soloing on
hard I think I'm fine
let's discuss it a few from Zim's Mary
and of smugglers of course they probably
sell first it'll score points for sin if
we get back
like that and a frost shard seems like
really good like I'd almost want like if
I had a storm on my team and no I wasn't
playing storm that like I'd want them to
have it
well rapping on the wrong way princess
no
the name of the game is anthem
I'm gonna guys kind of snipe them my
diet for it
oh he's using the like a laser fusion
cutter thing that the Ranger has like
not getting greens still common loot the
Ranger is supposed to be better now cuz
he's gonna help take shields down
quicker I think which was like kind of a
problem in the demo I feel like fries
and combo with melee yeah I mean for the
smaller guy sure but I can't freeze the
earth six the freezing the lightning is
also a combo that's to be seen Bobby teh
the commoner yeah right dude I remember
those those sick stronghold demo days
with like triple blue drops can't even
buy a green right now they call me Eric
at the grey man I guess
melee Rex okay I'll try that Swanson Ron
thanks appreciate all the tips through
this stream and you tuning in though
okay Ranger is apparently the only class
that will have shield piercing well then
you definitely need to have one of those
I think some people in the office were
telling me that the Ranger was one of
the highest damaging detonators at least
in demo with his alt rockets as long as
you combo Dean's or as long assembly
primary dick firm the storm is a long
distance javelin I'd like to think that
but the melee thing is pretty cool
really interesting Eric the 13-year old
yeah I guess so
any snow areas or different planets not
yet there's definitely gonna have a
cutscene is there purple rarity in this
game yet there's purple and gold I think
what gun are using I have technically
the Legion at dawn one the Scout and
then also had a pistol just messing
around princess she's just a crazy
smuggler with delusions of grandeur I
got blues at 15 alien I can't remember
if I got sooner but yeah energy combos
is a single target burst the shield
piercing is gear item a scene in
component so it's not a base ability you
think it's a component
who dat
deal who is this huh look it's your girl
okay please invite your old one is the
review come out probably next week well
probably like a review in progress
your than that Bell first we celebrate
our new partnership in the tradition of
my people come closer
friend of hallo
scoff at interesting are highly acidic
is going to burn going down a lot you
know I had okay
best not she's a princess yeah
oh boy is my ignorance princess I didn't
know people could eat this I come from a
harsh and unforgiving left sides are
scarce animals even more so before the
Dominion conquered us we had a saying we
understood it helped make us strong
thanks for the meal princess much was
just the appetizer
[Applause]
the main course behold the pheromone
sack of a young maanteeeca
cure for time
in a vat the fermented coming baby words
are a delicacy I have been saving for a
special occasion after you princess
I could not dishonor myself by eating
while my guests go hungry
I love magic our deal
what I straight up 8,000 you sure to
thank your friend that look I just need
to sit down for a second
there are in Tarsus Samir but you only
get two options I'm not even sure this
is Owen cipher and Lancer in the making
Corvus sent me
Corvus well you some kind of a hotshot
now you've got a lot of nerve after all
this time quit being dramatic sit down
I'd rather stand I'll go back to the
Strider I'll explain we got our own
thing going thanks but no wait
something's not right
[Music]
keep your friends safe cutscene this is
all well and good but where is their DRT
don't worry it's coming a little later
today it's gonna happen today though
it'll it'll be released today rather
it's just not at its normal time it's
been a crazy week lifeless satellites so
pardon the slight delay but yeah oh
we're still in here what
[Applause]
[Applause]
those guys are buff guys hurt pretty bad
these guys
wasn't worth it
oh this is not good okay
[Applause]
oh that's not good well then it just
straight up crashed oops wrong house oh
let's try to get back in there I guess
I want to finish the mission that's why
box night the one thing I know they
fixed is the the loading bug the 95
percent loading bug but that's about it
I might even have problems getting back
in because earlier I uh you know
what GPU at 1070 does that happen a lot
no that's my firt that kind of crashes
my first time what happened last time I
don't remember what happened last night
I think that's the first time I think
storm epic crash yeah
the only the only good news is you can
at least get back into it why do you use
the mage I don't know I picked storm and
I thought at level six I was gonna get
to do another one because that's what
even the load screen tips say like 2 6
18 and 26 but for some reason when I
went to javelins and forage I didn't
have another unlock and I don't know if
I'm screwing something out but we're
basically gonna finish this mission
again thank you all for tuning into game
SWAT live today on Friday to February 15
to 15 there's a lot of games coming out
anthem is one of them
well it doesn't technically like release
release till the 22nd because that's
when place is also out on PlayStation
did you change the things back to normal
no I'm playing on hard because I wanted
to see if the loot if there'd be a loot
difference or not but I haven't really
seen one we didn't get any greens yet
but it's not the end of the mission so
there's still a chance I'll still at it
man I appreciate your devotion thanks
converse I'm gonna get out of here soon
though because I'm gonna finish this
mission chasity and Ben will be back at
11:30 for a metro Exodus launch stream
so come check that out if you guys I
know some people are earlier we're like
oh yeah cool like Metro I'm gonna play
that you want to come hang out that's
awesome oh cool I literally have been
what please select another expedition
rip do I have to do that whole cutscene
the thing over again I can't even get
rid of the connection problem thing oh
there you go
uh I think it's too early for me to tell
you that Commander Shepard from the
little bit I played so far I think you
could totally play for a single player
as a single player like person that
likes it the crashes happen more on hard
mode really that seems kind of bad so
I'm guessing I'm in Tarsus and I'm
guessing I don't get to finish that
mission or if I'm super lucky my
teammates somehow beat it and that's why
I couldn't rejoin the expedition was
because there was no expedition to join
we'll find out so you're basically
saying what I said earlier which is I
should just play normal time bro how's
the Warlock class it's fun I like all
the abilities that the storm has and
it's fun comboing them for sure I'm
definitely in for Tarsus though I would
imagine I think the only way that if my
theory was there was an expedition to
join back on comes true is if Oh yep see
they finished it while I joined back
that's what happened we don't know how
that even happened what he's disaster
Kenny Brown haven't reached and game
enough but like from what I can tell and
see it's kind of like that with some
Mass Effect as well you matchmaking
story missions I was Jose just because
once you start your expedition your
match makes you I think what's your
favorite ability with storm um so far by
the lightning or I like any ice ability
though Carlito I think it'll be
primarily ps4 not sure I'm sorry PC but
I'm not sure if there
years also going to play x-box and PS
worth
it's good to see you again
is it you're not just here because you
need something it doesn't matter what am
i drinking there that coffee not I
cannot wait I'm gonna get a cup of
coffee after this I was able to get back
on GMAT I haven't had too many like
login issues but I've definitely what
now had like three crashes maybe in the
span of three hours so almost like a
crashing Alec senator game says I'm not
even worried about story that's kind of
how I was I mean it for the luteal it's
not interesting then
please hurry this up they'll be on top
of us any minute now
flyers
so what are you doing here I'm helping
you fix this garbage actuator again more
reliable than some so what's this
contract of yours the Dominion will be
here any second please this is important
just you're not helping yeah
Oh win I don't know if I missed part of
the cutscene Kenny the driver which one
use your words three eight I'm guessing
not I'm guessing you win that fight and
then you're here
really the Dominion wants the Cenotaph
chorus hired me to get it first well
that explains why Dominion troops showed
up at Zim's tell you later
the attention to detail on what jump in
the end and claim credit requires an
answer right now
sooner we work together no I can handle
it
Dominion on your back and you don't
think that maybe you could use a hand we
could find someone else you go right
ahead mate not in time we can't you need
me and I can't finish this contract
without you one job
just one
I got a Strider to drive you said you
have a lead we might as expected hold
these please
you found something eh Zim du hast have
friends you know huh some friends I'm
sure you've heard of the Legion of dawn
general Tarsus what general Tarsus yeah
he entered the last heart of Rage and
reached the center the Senate half how
I've done the research her javelin could
do the impossible it had unique shields
and who knows what else
wait wait you think you found her armor
the original javelin of dawn yes finally
no we just need to go get it interested
personally I can't wait to see it give
me whatever Intel her Highness had and
let's get the expedition started no need
I'll be supporting this mission I've
already done all the relevant research
right yeah that makes sense yeah see ya
Owen uh there's a past fully Cooley
arrived back to the Tarsus so that was
about I mean by the time I started and
you guys whoever lasted the three hours
that was about three hours I only I was
only about two three missions like the
easier missions in so that's kind of
like a taste of what you could expect
I'm still kind of shocked I for whatever
reason I not get loot what happened
that's new I think I think those are
both you know that would have been from
I don't even know it's weird though
because I thought I had another
traveling but a lot to figure that out
Tess you have to talk to her I hear
you've been busy try your keep I had a
good feeling about you ever since you
for Tom got no argument here it's the
heart of rage
I didn't know what what happened then or
what happy he's stuck around yeah I
wasn't meant to be here myself
what happened catechu you never got to
ante him glad you feel the same which
reminds me I should run check in your
javelin before your thanks so I'll see
you around huh so not Zoe
Oh I'll talk to her real quick
freelancer I trust your reunion with
Halligan Fay was productive always good
I did press why you saw the prompt there
wasn't like a hey do you want to unlock
another javelin well we're still getting
reacquainted make it work in the
meantime
Corvus has other jobs that might
interest you you know me if you don't
get Lou cutter free plane come back
contracts they're tough I can handle it
Russian if you want I know would you
ever the case keep
here I'm gonna show you that I did what
you said even though I just got debated
and there you go
alrighty that is where we are gonna end
today come back in about an hour and 15
minutes to to catch Metro Exodus launch
livestream with Ben and Jessie I really
do appreciate everyone that's hung out
and given tips or just had a chat about
the game it's always fun if you haven't
hit subscribe you should so you know
when we go live it's lemon am normally
Pacific Monday to Friday we're actually
off on Monday so after today's next
stream probably won't see you guys and
gals until Tuesday but yeah we'll be
back and yeah see you guys later bye